zone Europe sur sensation
[Musique]
il y a des vélos il y a des trams
qui font l'amour au carrefour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qui chantent les rêves qu'il est en et
je m'en vais faire un tour du côté de
chez soi revoir mon premier amour qui me
donnait rendez-vous
sous le Cher bonsoir et bienvenue dans
un Europe sur Radio sensation et sur
tv78 nous sommes à Amsterdam ici il y a
plus de vélo que d'habitants mais la
ville est aussi connue pour ses canaux
ses maisons étroites et pour avoir été
au 17e siècle la capitale économique du
monde
sur sensation
[Musique]
les Pays-Bas sont un des membres
fondateurs de l'Union européenne mais
qu'en pense aujourd'hui les jeunes
générations en France 52% des jeunes
estiment que l'UE ne joue pas un rôle
important dans leur vie de tous les
jours est-ce que c'est le cas ici au
Pays-Bas j'ai rendez-vous avec Marlena
eichen d'horizon européen à Amsterdam
zone Europe sur sensation
nous sommes maintenant avec Marlena la
présidente de européen horizon et avec
Sean le vice-président bonjour bonjour
merci d'être avec nous dans une Europe
first d'abord quelles sont les objectifs
d'horizon européen
l'objectif principal d'horizon européen
en particulier ici à Amsterdam et de
créer une plateforme permettant aux
étudiants de s'engager de manière
critique dans les affaires de l'Union
européenne et Sean peut développer un
peu plus l'émission de notre
organisation
simplement notre mission est de
favoriser une Europe fortement unie et
transatlantique parce que nous croyons
au fondement d'un avenir dans lequel la
démocratie l'égalité la liberté sont au
premier plan nous pouvons compter sur
notre réseau de plus de 60 associations
pour faire ça et nous sommes l'une
d'entre elles
United votre vision est de défendre une
Europe plus unie mais que voulez-vous
dire
pour nous une reprise unie veut dire que
nous sommes capables de discuter de
créer du débat pour avoir ces
discussions pas seulement entre
étudiants aux personnes de notre pays
mais aussi avec des personnes avec
d'autres visions d'autres pays donc
quand vous venez chez Horizon européen
nous avons des associations dont
différents pays de l'Union européenne et
en écoutant différents étudiants en
écoutant différentes voix nous
améliorons nos connaissances nos
perspectives et faisons nos critiques
sur les affaires européennes
ignore
nationalités quelles sont les
nationalités qui sont représentées ici à
Amsterdam
je peux commencer peut-être cela montre
que nous sommes très multiculturel moi
je suis polonaise notre trésorier
japonais nous avons aussi des gens
moi-même je suis néerlandais américain
cela apporte beaucoup de perspectives de
différents points de vue géographiques
pourquoi pensez-vous que c'est
intéressant de penser d'un point de vue
européen et pas d'un point de vue
national
je pense que c'est très important de
penser d'un point de vue européen mais
pas seulement d'un point de vue
transnational c'est pourquoi la
perspective transatlantique est aussi
très importante ici face au symbole du
point de vue national car nous sommes
aujourd'hui confrontés aux montées des
tendances il libéral aller à la menace
du changement climatique ces défis ne
peuvent pas être résolus à l'intérieur
de nos propres frontières il faut le
prendre en compte et coopérer entre les
peuples du monde entier
exactement dans la perspective
européenne l'unité est très importante
car nous pouvons le voir sans unité très
peu de choses peuvent être faites à
l'intérieur d'un pays pas seulement sur
un continent mais partout dans le monde
les gens veulent avoir leur mot à dire à
l'air mondiale et nous devons être
vraiment ensemble
to you to defend c'est très important
pour vous de défendre une Union
européenne très unique en ce moment nous
connaissons vous le savez tous une crise
énergétique en Europe c'est l'occasion
pour augmenter notre indépendance afin
de mieux défendre les valeurs
européennes à l'avenir
yes of course oui bien sûr ça l'est
surtout pour un problème crucial qui est
la dépendance énergétique de devenir de
plus en plus indépendant cependant c'est
un aspect très compliqué pas vrai
parce qu'il y a eu des traités qui nous
ont empêché en quelque sorte de venir
indépendant comme le traité de la Charte
énergétique c'est très complexe mais
cette crise contre que nous devons
trouver les solutions pour être
indépendants
des pays amis l'Europe peut maintenir
son indépendance énergétique en
remplaçant le gaz provenant de Russie
les Pays-Bas étaient d'ailleurs l'un des
pays les plus dépendants de ce gaz
maintenant nous voyons que les solutions
ne peuvent se trouver uniquement chez
nous il faut se tourner vers nos
partenaires qui peuvent augmenter leur
production de gaz je pense par exemple
aux États-Unis
et pour finir quels sont les événements
et projets que vous mènerez cette année
[Musique]
alors nous avons un déplacement à Gans
fin septembre c'est pour participer à
une compétition de horizon européen nous
avons aussi créé une coopération avec
l'Université de Bruxelles et grâce à
Solan nous allons créer une équipe
d'étudiants pour écrire de très bons
papiers lors de cette compétition à
gagner et puis qu'à ton Autre
[Musique]
Shop généralement nous faisons des
ateliers et nous nous concentrons sur le
développement des compétences des jeunes
on essaie aussi à travers ces ateliers
de réaliser des événements qui peuvent
être l'opportunité pour les étudiants
d'écrire pour nous ou même pour une
publication
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous
dans une Europe
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'on mange au Pays-Bas du
gouda du hareng de la soupe aux pois
nous avons rendez-vous avec Alain Caron
un Chef français installé ici depuis 40
ans on le retrouve dans l'un de ses
restaurants à Amsterdam
zone Europe sur sensation
bonjour Alain Caron bonjour Alors on dit
de vous que vous êtes l'ambassadeur de
la gastronomie française ici au Pays-Bas
alors pourquoi est-ce que vous avez
décidé de vous installer ici il y a 40
ans maintenant alors je suis pas venu
pour les tulipes je suis pas venu pour
les harengs je suis venu parce que j'ai
été amoureux d'une hollandaise tout
simplement
un an je travaillais à Paris et à un
moment j'ai décidé de venir alors quand
vous êtes arrivés ici il y a 40 ans
qu'est-ce que vous a le plus surpris
culinairement parlant c'est qu'il y
avait rien
c'est à dire dans les supermarchés il y
avait une demi-bouteille d'huile d'olive
il y avait des fromages pasteurisés il y
avait la viande était il servait à
l'époque la viande très très très
fraîche
donc donc oui c'est tellement alors moi
ce qui m'a le plus surprise avec
quelques jours que je goûte la cuisine
néerlandaise le midi c'est très très
léger on m'a servi une tartine de pain
avec du gouda de la salade et une soupe
de pois voilà alors rassurez-moi il y a
pas que ça dans la cuisine néerlandais
quand même non il y a pas que ça c'est
tendance vous savez les Irlandais ils
sont ils sont très ils sont il y a
beaucoup de végétariens ici mais
vraiment énormément donc dans tous les
menus qu'on a nous par exemple ici dans
nos restaurants et ailleurs il y a
toujours des plats végétaliens mais le
Hollandais en fait il déjeune pas comme
nous en France trois plats et le soir
trois plats et un petit déjeuner copieux
non eux ce qu'ils font c'est un déjeuner
petit déjeuner copieux avec du fromage
avec des latences avec
si vous voulez du yaourt avec de
confiture du bon pain voilà ça ils font
ça et le minime il mange presque pas
donc par contre le soir il mange tôt
parce qu'ils ont faim et 18h voilà mais
bon maintenant il y a des très très
beaux restaurants moi ça fait 40 ans que
je suis ici il y a de très bons
restaurants étoilés il y a des très bons
il y a des très bonnes brasseries il y a
beaucoup de Français qui ont des
restaurants tu peux manger italien
vraiment très très bien tu peux manger
coréen très bien tu peux manger
internationalement internationalement
c'est beaucoup mieux qu'avant vraiment
est-ce qu'il a quand même des
similitudes entre la cuisine française
et cuisine hollandaise
pur pas vraiment c'est vraiment
choucroute on va parler soupe de pommes
de terre avec avec des endives on va
parler
jambon endives même sans fromage non non
il y a pas de vraiment de similitude par
contre ce qui est incroyable c'est que
les Hollandais avec leur casse
ils font de la nourriture et ils
envoient de la nourriture partout dans
le monde c'est les plus forts
et en même temps moi je fais un
programme qui s'appelle
intérieur extérieur et là on fait
beaucoup de moi je vois tous les
producteurs en Hollande ça fait 7 7 ans
que je tourne partout et croyez-moi il y
a vraiment ils ont tout ici ils ont de
la super volaille ils ont de l'agneau
qui est très très bon dans les îles ils
ont des produits laitiers qui sont
admirables les poissons on n'a pas pas
ils ont tout ils ont tout seulement il
faut chercher parce qu'ils ont pas de
ils arrivent pas à faire des connexions
pour faire des bons marchés dans toute
la Hollande trop difficile
un importateur de pomme qui a 200 km
l'autre qui vont ses carottes il a 100
km ils arrivent pas à faire une cohésion
ça c'est dommage il y a quelques marchés
où ils font ça qui sont très très bons
par exemple marché du Sud à Amsterdam
marché du Nord à Amsterdam c'est un peu
cher mais on peut tout trouver quand
vous vous baladez à Amsterdam les gens
vous vous salue dans la rue ils vous
reconnaissent notamment parce que vous
étiez juré de l'émission MasterChef ici
au Pays-Bas vous former aussi dans vos
restaurants des chefs néerlandais est-ce
qu'ils sont aussi bons que qu'en France
quelle question
je peux pas répondre en France on a une
culture culinaire qui est énorme quand
les gamins ils arrivent chez nous
ils se demandent ah ouais là il y en a
un qui est arrivé qui se dire ah c'est
ça la cuisine un garçon c'est ça la
cuisine c'est pas moi qui forme c'est
mes chefs qui font donc voilà parce que
moi je tourne à droite à gauche dans
tous les restaurants mais c'est eux qui
forment on les a formés ils font la
cuisine qu'on veut et maintenant il
continue vous avez quatre restaurants
ici à Amsterdam que peut-on y manger
alors alors ici par exemple café Caron
c'est bistronomy et aussi légitarien on
a un chef qu'il faut aller très très
bons plats végétarien et on essaie de
changer un petit peu la cuisine de
bistrot à notre goût dans le bistrotony
on a un restaurant un bar qui s'appelle
petit Caron là on mange des produits
très simples mais il y a beaucoup de
sortes de vin on a la cantine de Caron
on peut on peut avoir 300 personnes par
jour et là c'est
côte de bœuf c'est des grosses des
salades de betterave c'est un peu comme
on dit c'est un peu
je vous dirai en hollandais on dit rue
c'est pur bam voilà on a des volaille
mais c'est cuit en entier on a des
desserts au chocolat on a des sorbets
qui sont servis dans des dans des
couples et
après on a le
comment s'appelle c'est
le premier restaurant où j'ai travaillé
quand je suis venu finalement la repris
avec mes fils et là c'est cuisine
française revue corriger mais classique
parce que le chef est français et il
vient de de
Bourgogne et Thomas on le laisse faire
on le laisse aller un petit peu parce
qu'il cuisine très bien donc on goûte et
maintenant avant on disait ouais ça joue
pas ça je suis comme ça maintenant on
dit tu changes rien quand on dit tu
changes rien c'est sa cuisine vous avez
écrit plusieurs livres de gastronomie à
la fois en hollandais à la fois en
français mais vous avez vous partagez la
gastronomie française néerlandais
quelles sont les plats qu'il raffolent
le plus qu'est-ce qu'il leur plaisent le
plus de nos plats français ils adorent
la côte de bœuf il s'adore la volaille
entière nous on fait une volaille Abu
ferraille ici on a énormément et ils
adorent les poissons crus ils adorent
tout ce qui est souple
mais bon il faut ils ont évolué aussi il
faut ils savent ce qui est bon donc
en tout cas nous ils aiment tout ce
qu'on fait donc on est bien donc ça va
mais des plats vraiment spécifiques
de l'agneau ils adorent parce qu'ils
savent que c'est ce que c'est que ce que
c'est que l'agneau
ils adorent les plats les biens bien
fait en sauce les sauces
et pour finir à un Caron comment est-ce
qu'on dit bon appétit en néerlandais
d'avoir été avec nous dans un endroit de
sensation
[Musique]
[Rires]
ou encore Martin garrix voici quelques
artistes originaires des Pays-Bas
aujourd'hui dans une Europe on va vous
faire découvrir un jeune chanteur
néerlandais c'est notre artiste coup de
cœur il s'appelle Elia
robe sur sensation
hello
merci d'être avec nous dans zone Europe
vous êtes l'un des artistes les plus
prometteurs des Pays-Bas votre musique
est un mixte de hip-hop et darnb et de
rock vous êtes souvent comparé à Harry
Styles et un chanteur australien The Kid
la Roy comment est-ce que vous décririez
votre musique
je décrirai ma musique comme je la
ressens je dirais un mix entre du
hip-hop et du rap mais il y a des
mouvements qui vont vers d'autres genres
par exemple la pop rock aussi bien juste
de la pop mais actuellement je ressens
surtout l'envie de faire de beaux
singles dans ses principaux styles
waterlio mosquée
vos chanteurs favoris vos inspirations
il y a beaucoup d'artistes qui
m'inspirent mais maintenant je dirais
vraiment qui de la Roy un artiste que
j'admire vraiment et aussi juice World
deux très bons artistes je suis inspiré
par eux quasiment tous les jours
il y a beaucoup de DJ néerlandais très
célèbres Armin van Buuren dans le Diablo
Martin garrix
pourquoi est-ce que c'est plus difficile
selon vous de devenir très célèbre
lorsque l'on est un chanteur néerlandais
sont plus célèbres si on les compare aux
artistes néerlandais
c'est compliqué pour moi de dire
pourquoi c'est comme ça mais en y
réfléchissant là tout de suite c'est
peut-être parce qu'il y a 10 ans
l'univers musical était différent de
celui d'aujourd'hui il y a eu une large
période où vous pouviez créer de la
musique en étant chez vous dans votre
chambre cela a aidé les DJ ils peuvent
toujours démarrer tout seul mais c'est
une question compliquée c'est difficile
pour moi de comparer
d'avoir une carrière à la Martin garrix
par exemple
j'aimerais déjà qu'un jour je puisse
vivre de la musique et faire ça à temps
plein je travaille pour ça
Martin garrix c'est très connu je ne
pourrais pas dire que je rêve de faire
une carrière comme ça mais bien sûr si
j'ai l'opportunité je foncerai mais
actuellement je ne peux pas rêver de
cela Martin garrix et beaucoup trop loin
de moi pour ça maintenant je vous
propose qu'on écoute tout de suite un
extrait de votre single ça s'appelle
Brock my heart
[Musique]
est-ce que l'idée de venir et de chanter
en France vous plairait un jour
je suis déjà allé plusieurs fois en
France pour les vacances je pense que
c'est un grand pays les gens sont très
chaleureux où avez-vous été en France
je suis allé à Paris et je suis allé à
Nice deux villes très connues et
agréables à vivre que pensez-vous de la
France qu'est-ce que ça représente pour
vous
la France représente pour moi des gens
en chaleureux les vacances aussi et un
temps ensoleillé
quel est votre chanteur français préféré
je ne connais pas beaucoup de chanteurs
français mais je dirais quand même
Stromae il est très connu et a fait le
grand hit je suis toujours très heureux
de l'écouter Stromae qui est évidemment
belge et pas français
et ici au Pays-Bas quels sont les salles
de concert emblématiques dans lesquelles
vous aimeriez un jour faire un concert
j'ai encore beaucoup de chemin parcourir
mais ce serait un rêve de jouer aux
musicodom c'est un peu l'endroit où il
faut être pour tout artiste qui vit au
Pays-Bas
sont en anglais et pas en néerlandais
est-ce que vous pensez un jour sortir un
single en néerlandais
j'ai déjà essayé d'écrire mes chansons
en néerlandais mais pour diverses
raisons je n'ai pas pu partager mon
message émotionnel c'est pourquoi je
chante seulement en anglais en ce moment
cela me va car je peux avoir un public
international et c'est l'un des
meilleurs avantages de chanter en
anglais
vous n'êtes pas d'Amsterdam vous venez
de la zone frontalière avec l'Allemagne
quelles sont les autres villes à visiter
et à découvrir au Pays-Bas tout
pour les Français oui
je pense qu'il y a beaucoup de beaux
endroits même si les Pays-Bas sont très
petits en moins de deux heures vous êtes
complètement à la campagne vous l'avez
d'ailleurs expérimenté vous-même alors
je dirais
U13 au milieu des Pays-Bas
et harnais aussi un beau lieu à
découvrir je pense et pour finir cette
interview qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire sur vos prochains singles au
prochain featuring new featuring par
exemple
pour parler avec des DJ et je vais
sortir un son avec un gros DJ qui vient
d'Algérie il fait de l'afro pop et oui
nous allons collaborer ça devrait faire
un très bon son nous sommes en train de
travailler dessus voilà ce que je peux
vous en dire
merci beaucoup Elia d'avoir été avec
nous dans un Europe je rappelle donc que
vous êtes un jeune chanteur néerlandais
et on se quitte nous en musique avec le
titre promesse sur Radio sensation
[Musique]
zone Europe c'est terminé vous pouvez
retrouver cette émission en replay sur
notre application et sur notre site
internet radio sensation et aussi sur TV
118 nous on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
Amsterdam
[Musique]
il y a des vélos et il y a des trams
et des bateaux qui font l'amour au
carrefour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qui chantent les rêves qu'il est en
temps et je m'en vais faire un tour du
côté de chez soi revoir mon premier
amour qui me donnait rendez-vous
sous le Cher
son Europe sur sensation
[Musique]